all the pretty girls walk like this this
this this this this this this pretty
girls walk like this okay cardi B and
offset's daughter culture struts her
stuff for her pretty girl walk and cardi
went full pageant mom this this this
this this this
snap snap cardi shared that Sassy clip
to her Instagram on Tuesday with the
caption okay bestie pretty girls walk
like this this this this this this this
but like all season Stars culture
requested a take two for safety so let's
take it from the top oh the pretty girls
walk like this this this this this this
this this a little oh okay period
because I just want to show people how
beautiful and how precious she is no
notes culture no notes
of course it's hardly the first time
culture has stolen the show
in May offset took the little one and
her big sis Kalia to The Little Mermaid
Premiere where they made a splash on the
blue carpet rocking black and white
princess gowns and get this they even
met Ariel herself Hallie Bailey
[Music]
and sure sometimes cardi gives culture
notes ready
all the pretty girls walk like this this
this this this this
but earlier this month the shoe was on
the other foot when culture had some
opinions about mom's cooking okay guys
so this is the final product day six
today's tomatoes
[Laughter]
but cooking skills aside it's no secret
cardi loves being a mommy to her kiddos
I love everything about motherhood she
regularly shares little glimpses into
her everyday life with culture and baby
brother wave I'm going to
a massage gun and buying some toys for
my kids because they behave so she
behaved so good
while I was in the gym I just love my
babies what does it mean to be a mother
it means everything it's like
like
love joy it's a switch you know what I'm
saying it's like automatic smile it's
always everything it's everything yeah
she means everything so whether culture
slays or catwalk walk like this this
this this
this this stunts on the red carpet or
delivers the honest truth hey stick face
[Laughter]
she has her parents full support
foreign
[Music]